welcome back
now we're going to be talking about one
of the most important concepts that's
useful for robust control
in particular we're going to be talking
about the loop transfer function so
essentially
i'm going to be talking about the
transfer function
that includes just the controller and
the plant in open loop without any
feedback so i just want to think about
this transfer function
and the various tran the various
properties of this transfer function are
extremely important to quantify
performance and robustness so here are
some of our goals of feedback
and i like thinking about these in terms
of active kind of verbs so i want to
design my system for stability i want to
compensate for model uncertainty i want
to reject disturbances and i want to
attenuate noise in my system those are
all things i want to do with feedback
and we're going to find that we're able
to look at all of those in terms of
properties of this simple loop transfer
function
so here i'm going to have my output y
this is going to be some
epsilon error
because we're going to be looking at a
reference
value
where we're subtracting off measurements
from that reference value
we're also going to add in a disturbance
model d
so plus
d
we're going to add in some noise
n
in fact i think i should probably modify
this a little bit so
we're going to have the disturbance
before the output so we're going to have
some plus
and maybe my disturbance actually has a
transfer function of its own we're going
to call this p
d
and d feeds into that transfer function
and then this is why the output
and y measured is with noise okay so
hopefully this makes sense i have my
system p
i that system p is a clean system but
there's disturbances that get added to
the state or to the output
oftentimes this disturbance transfer
function will be a lot like the plant
transfer function they might even be
identical so i have some real output y
that has disturbances so if this is my
pendulum on a cart maybe there's wind
blowing that's that's disturbing the
system
maybe my measurement has noise on it so
maybe i'm measuring the angle but my
encoder has some noise on it so i have a
noisy measurement
i feed that noisy measurement back and
subtract it from my reference so
reference tells me where i want y to be
i subtract the true measured y and this
gives me an error signal
i use that error signal i pass it
through the controller it tells me what
my actuation u should be that goes
through my system and hopefully
the
that passes through the dynamics to make
y closer to reference making epsilon
small we want small error okay
and we want to again be able to handle
rejecting disturbances so even if
there's relatively large disturbances we
wanted to design k
so that disturbances don't pass through
to epsilon we want to have good noise
attenuation we don't want noise to get
through to epsilon so we want the
controller to act in a way that doesn't
amplify measurement noise
and we also want to have robust stable
high performance properties
so we want good performance of p
and we want to have robustness in case
our model for p is a little different
than reality okay
and so what we're going to look at is
these special transfer functions
based on this loop transfer function so
let me just
mark this out so here
is what we're going to be calling our
loop
transfer function l so l is for
our loop l
okay that's our loop transfer function
l
equals p
times k
and i always kind of reverse the order
that i draw them so if it goes k into p
then the transfer function is p times k
because epsilon first passes through k
then passes through p and that's the
output so this is kind of operator
notation
and if we start dealing with systems
that have multiple inputs and multiple
outputs then these are going to be
matrices and you're going to need to be
careful about what order you order these
and this is the right order okay so the
loop transfer function is p times k
and we're going to be looking at how
this error depends on properties of this
loop transfer function
all right uh so there's going to be some
math what we're going to do first of all
is
i'm going to write down
y as a function of d and n and r
okay
and so what we're going to have is
first of all we're going to have um
okay good we're going to have
y equals
my disturbances p pd times d
plus
p times k
of epsilon and what's epsilon it's just
r minus all of this stuff okay so that's
times r
minus y m
and y m is just y plus n so r minus y
minus n
okay and just to make a note this is
just
epsilon
okay so my output y is just my
disturbance
plus my loop transfer function times
epsilon and i'm writing it in terms of y
because i want to bring all of my y's
over to one side and write this as y
equals a function of disturbance
reference and noise
okay
okay so let's do that let's bring my y's
over so this is
and i'm going to act like these are all
matrices i'm going to act like this is
multiple like a vector of inputs u and a
vector of outputs y and so these are
kind of matrix transfer functions
and so this is a matrix
and i'm going to bring it over and i'm
going to have
i can put an identity
i can say this is identity times y
so i
plus
p k
y all i've done is i brought this y term
times p k over to the left hand side
this equals
pk reference
okay
pk reference
um
plus
p d disturbance
minus
p
k
noise pretty simple okay
and then i can solve for y
by inverting this um so in general we
hope that this is invertible
and we say y equals
now since this is a matrix i'm not going
to do divided by i'm going to do a left
inverse
identity plus p k
inverse times p k times r
plus
identity plus p k
inverse
p d times disturbance
minus
identity plus p k
inverse
p k
times noise
okay
and so now what i have is the output of
my system y
is this big transfer function
so a transfer function times reference
plus a transfer function times
disturbance plus a transfer function
times noise
and what i'm going to want is i'm going
to want to design k
so that all of these transfer functions
have desirable properties and we'll get
into what desirable means in a little
bit
but the idea is
we're going to try to design the
controller so that we have good
reference tracking so that y equals r
we're going to try to design k so that
disturbances are rejected so that this
is a small transfer function at least
for frequencies where we expect
disturbances
and we're going to choose k to make this
transfer function really small at
frequencies where we think that noise is
important so high frequencies we're
going to make this small probably low
frequencies we're going to make this
slow because remember in our cruise
controller our disturbances were these
low frequency hills
and we're going to try to make this um
as big as possible
for low frequencies because we want to
be able to track references of low
frequencies okay
um
and so what we end up doing
is giving these names so we say that
identity plus pk inverse pk
we call this the
okay we call um
this one i plus pk inverse
the sensitivity so kind of how sensitive
is my output to disturbances
we call this one the complementary
sensitivity t
and notice that i have the complementary
sensitivity t
on both noise and reference okay
and this is kind of neat so i have these
new transfer functions that tell me how
my system reacts to references
disturbances and noise
and if i want i can write those in terms
of my loop transfer function so i have s
equals
i plus l inverse
and i have t
the so sensitivity s complementary
sensitivity t
t
is just i
plus l inverse
times l times another l
and so you can write out the math and
it's pretty easy to show that if i add s
plus t i have to get the identity matrix
okay so if i say
s plus t
is always equal to the identity matrix
for all frequencies everywhere this has
to be true these are transfer functions
so these are functions kind of in the
laplace variable
but if i add
identity plus l
times identity plus l inverse those
cancel out
and that's why this is called the
sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity because they're complements
they always add up to the identity for
every frequency uh little s the laplace
transform variable
okay so what we're going to do next is
we're going to rewrite instead of
looking at y in terms of these transfer
functions we're going to look at epsilon
in terms of these transfer functions and
then we're going to see what are the
properties we want s and t and
eventually l to have so that epsilon has
good properties in terms of reference
disturbance and noise so that's all
coming up um
stay tuned this is one of the most
important concepts we're getting towards
robustness we're going to figure out
what it means to have high performance
and robustness in terms of these
transfer functions
okay thank you